Вони задихаються від шкідливих вихлопних газів.
ак активісти Грінпіс зустрічали
рішення так званого "дизельного саміту",
на якому уряд Німеччини спільно з провідними німецькими автоконцернами погодили,
що автовиробники за свій рахунок
проведуть оновлення програмного забезпечення,
яке регулює систему вихлопних газів.
Для цього відкличуть понад 5 мільйонів дизельних автомобілів.
Утім, німецькі водії вважають це певною мірою окозамилюванням,
мовляв, це не вирішить проблеми забруднення повітря
і не поверне довіри покупців.
Я відчуваю себе обдуреним.
Моя машина ще зовсім нова.
Тепер не знаю, що з нею робити.
Вони повинні знайти рішення для нашої планети,
для екосистеми, для наших дітей,
щоб більше не було шкоди довкіллю.
Власники дизельних автівок вважають, що автоконцерни
мали запропонувати якесь глобальніше рішення.
Оновлення програмного забезпечення
скоротить отруйні викиди оксидів азоту
лише на 20-30 відсотків,
а за деякими даними лише на 10 відсотків
Екологи вже давно домагаються повної заборони
дизельних автівок у німецьких містах.
У водіїв дизельних автівок це викликає майже паніку.
Після того, як автовиробники викидають на вітер мільярди,
для них було б дешевше модернізувати наші машини.
І мені байдуже, як вони це зроблять.
Оновлення програмного забезпечення коштуватиме близько ста євро на машину.
Це для автоконцернів значно дешевше,
аніж, приміром, технічно переоснастити дизельні машини таким чином,
щоб вони майже взагалі не викидали отруйних речовин.
Такі технології вже давно застосовують на вантажівках.
Утім, автовиробникам це обійдеться значно дорожче -
близько півтори тисячі євро на машину.
Сподіваюся, це усе не тільки через вибори.
І що вони влаштували цей саміт не просто щоб заспокоїти людей.
І політики, і автоконцерни запевняють, що рішення "дизельного саміту" -
тільки перший крок на шляху виходу з дизельної кризи.
І що власників автомобілів не змусять розплачуватися
за помилки автовиробників.